starting today millions of people will
experience a brand new Spotify the audio
streaming company will announce the
largest update to its platform at their
stream on event get it stream on event I
like that since it became available on
phones more than a decade ago first on
CBS mornings Spotify co-founder and CEO
that's Daniel Eck reveals what the new
Spotify will look like here's part of
the conversation
when people wake up and they go to
Spotify it will look different for them
yeah how so so uh there's a number of
new updates one of them is an entirely
new home feed so uh completely
redesigned from the ground up you'll see
Spotify I think come alive you're going
to see a lot more interactive content
you're going to see clips of content
that might be really interesting to you
that's being recommended to you and
you're going to be able to see visual
components for instance clips and videos
that people are uploading with that
content too we'll be able to scroll then
you're going to be able to scroll scroll
through those clips to find interesting
content for you so that's the first
change interesting content for you
tomorrow we'll have more of our
exclusive interview with Daniel Eck we
also got a tour of spotify's La campus
it is very cool there and met the voice
behind spotify's new AI DJ in the
interview Eck responds to claims that
Spotify doesn't pay artists enough money
and he talks about his decision to carry
Joe Rogan since very controversial
podcasts I I can't wait for you all to
see it number one he doesn't do very
many interviews so we thank Daniel Eck
and his team for letting us come there
but it's very cool they haven't even
thought about making any update or
changes to Spotify in the last 10 years
because they haven't needed to right
because it's not popular because it is
so popular it's still very popular
they've hit brand new numbers that are
like off the charts fantastic and he's
always he always thinks in the future
that's that's why I'm fascinated by him
he's thinking in the future what do we
need to do they're doing a pretty good
job of serving up what the audience is
looking for are they recommending dad
Rock to me right now
and uh Creedence Clearwater Revival so
they're not lying
okay spot on